تقول مهنة إدلب لك إنك
كنت تتصرف في وقت متأخر جدًا منذ عام 2011. لقد فقدت
كل شيء أحببته في أي وقت مضى ، لقد فقدت
كل ما أملكه ويخبرك
أننا لسنا مفيدين ، فنحن لا
نحترم حياة الإنسان
وحقوق الإنسان
[موسيقى  ]
لدينا بالأمس من يقول إنني فقدت
كل شيء في ساعتك
وأنت ترغب فقط في إلقاء اللوم على
الأعضاء الآخرين ، فأنت تلقي باللوم على روسيا
لمجرد دفع المسؤولية
بعيدًا عنك
[موسيقى] ،
أليس لديك أي نوع من الإنسانية
هل صرخت  إطلاقا كيف
تنام في الليل
كيف تبدو أطفالك
[موسيقى]
يقفون أمامك اليوم حاملين 14
رسالة مرسلة إليكم
من أعضاء مجلس الأمن من 14
سوريًا يمثلون جميع حكام سوريا السوريين. 14.
[موسيقى]
عبر  الحدود جاؤوا إلى سوريا وذبحوا
واغتصبوا وحرقوا الحيوانات والأشجار على حد سواء.
أليس لديك أي احترام
لمن يعانون منذ سنوات من
أجل كل من مات ، والتعذيب في
سوريا لكل أم
لم يكن لديك طفلها واحترم هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين تطبيعهم مع الأسد هو جريمة
عار عليك وعار على الأردني
في الأردن البلد الذي لا
يسمح للمرأة الحامل في معسكر المعجبين
بالذهاب إلى مستشفى آمن في الأردن
[موسيقى  ]
الولايات المتحدة
مؤخرًا
اقتصرت حكومتك على التصريحات الفارغة.